Віддайте мені дві гривні.
- У мене немає.
- Як немає?
Тільки великі купюри
Аферисти!
По голові собі стукни!
"Нелегальний перевізник" - іронічний міні-серіал
про життя таксистів, який зняли блогери.
А це його головний герой - таксист Сашко Шустрий
- Вези мене, мерзота!
- Я вас нікуди не повезу я не хочу
В реальному житті Сашко -  теж таксист. І теж нелегал.
Я, як і всі, нелегал. В мене з легального тільки одне -
- в мене страховка для роботи в таксі. Все!
В Україні таких, як Олександр, не менше 200 000 осіб.
Принаймні згідно з підрахункамиміністерства інфраструктури.
Насправді масштаб тіньового ринку може бути значно більшим - до 600 тисяч таксистів.
В цьому великому тіньовому секторі економіки є навіть окремі касти водіїв.
Так звані "бордюрщики" cтоять  на узбіччі і чекають того,
хто хоче заплатити в кілька разів більше за поїздку до вокзалу чи аеропорту.
"Фільтровщики" теж стоять на узбіччі і стежать за онлайн-службами таксі
в пошуках більш-менш вигідних замовлень.
"Підвезуни" - звичайні власники автомобілів, які хочуть компенсувати
витрати на пальне у своїх поїздках, тому шукають попутників.
І головна, найбільша за чисельністю каста - так звані "пилососи".
Я більше відношуся до "пилососів".
Бо  я вивожу все, що є на цьому ринку.  Всі замовлення!
Олександру - 25 років, таксистом він став два з половиною роки тому
повернувшись зі служби в ЗСУ.
Йому відверто не подобається працювати нелегально.
І ще більше не подобається те, що нелегальний ринок фактично знищує професію таксиста.
Зареєструватися водієм в онлайн-службах може фактично кожний.
Професійного відбору немає. Як результат -
вартість поїздок разом з прибутками зменшується.
Ринок таксі знецінений, його перестали приймати до уваги.
Якщо брати часи СРСР,
то працювати в таксі було елітно і перспективно.
Дуже багато водіїв приїжджають з регіонів, з областей.
Байдуже, що вони не знають міста, байдуже, що погано знають правила.
Я хоча і "пилосос",
але  я за устаканення ринку,
і за більше наведення ладу на ньому.
Олександр покладає надії на законопроєкт про врегулювання ринку таксі,
який наразі винесений на обговорення Мінінфраструктури.
Один з ініціаторів законопроєкту, Асоціація відповідальних перевізників,
хоче запропонувати державі і таксистам, на їхній погляд, просту схему виходу з тіні.
Патентування. Вартість - 5400 гривень на рік.
У випадку прийняття законопроекту, водій, який не має жодних документів,
повинен звернутися до держави, заявити про те,
що хоче здійснювати перевезення. При цьому ФОП створювати не потрібно.
Потрібно заплатити вартість патенту - мінімальну зарплату на рік.
І оформити страховий поліс на той випадок, що якщо трапиться ДТП,
щоб було зрозуміло, куди бігти водієві і пасажиру, щоб відновлювати своє здоров’я.
Центральний вокзал Києва - мекка для таксистів
Тут можна завжди знайти собі роботу.
Євген стоїть на одному з "хлібних місць".
Він розповідає, що працював таксистом на вокзалі в Луганську
і навіть вивозив людей з- під обстрілів.
До столиці переїхав приблизно 3 роки тому.
Глобально він за легалізацію таксі, проте ні про яке патентування чути не хоче.
Згоден! Потрібна легалізація.
Але спочатку нам треба роботу організувати.
Відкрити таксопарки, як в часи СРСР, щоб ми працювали на заробітній платі.
А не так, як ми! Купуємо автівки, влізаємо в кредити,
доріг немає, хоча ми платимо транспортний збір.
До речі, хочеться Зеленського спитати! Де гроші? Де дороги?
Я буду до останнього чекати і не буду купувати патент.
Подивитеся. Введуть патентування - підемо страйкувати!
З Євгеном, щоправда, згодні далеко не всі працівники так званого "вокзального таксопарку".
Кажуть, що патентування - це те, що вони готові розглянути як варіант легальної роботи.
Тим більше, що передбачувана його вартість - не захмарна.
Треба платити. Україну треба підняти, щоб пенсії підвищили,
хоча б до 3000 грн.
Якщо всі не будемо платити податки, то що це буде? Це буде безлад!
Весь світ платить і нормально живе.
Таксист, який купив шашечку, начепив ії на дах і сказав, що він таксист,
не буде платити. Це справа кожного.
Але має бути служба, яка це має контролювати.
Я, в принципі, не проти.
Ініціатори законопроєкту пропонують простий варіант задля здійснення контролю.
Усі таксисти, які хочуть бути легальними і придбають патент,
будуть внесені у відповідний реєстр, що не тільки спростить процедуру контролю,
але і пришвидшить перехід з тіньового сектору економіки в легальний.
В нашому законопроекті ми пропонуємо просту і ефективну схему контролю,
коли один перевіряючий, викликаючи будь-яке таксі з точки А в точку Б,
по приїзду, на місці буде здійснювати перевірку.
І якщо у водія не буде необхідних документів, він одразу буде оштрафований.
Насправді будь-який таксист може бути оштрафований вже сьогодні -
на 17 000 гривень.
Адже законодавством передбачено, що таксист працює легально,
якщо він зареєстрований як фізична особа-підприємець і має на це ліцензію.
Але таких законослухняних таксистів в Україні лише 2% від усієї армії таксистів.
Це приблизно 11 тисяч осіб. Максим - один з них.
Вважає, що ліцензій могло б бути більше, якби проводилися справжні перевірки.
Закон є! Нема кому виконувати.
Ви ж виконали?
У нас вимагає служба.
Ми б не змогли працювати в службі, якби не мали ліцензії.
Процедура притягнення до відповідальності водія без ліцензії
теж прописана в законодавстві.
Поліція, податкова, Укртрансбезпека мають проводити рейди,
зупиняти таксистів без ліцензії і штрафувати.
За останні 10 років в Україні було кілька спроб
провести реформу з легалізації ринку таксі.
Усі вони були невдалими через слабкий контроль за виконанням законів,
вважає київський адвокат Вадим Хабібуллін.
Експерт навіть судився з Національної поліцією України,
яка, на думку адвоката, не до кінця виконує свої обов’язки
щодо наведення порядку на трасах.
Було навіть рішення, яке зобов’язувало Національну поліцію
зупиняти кожну машину, яка може бути ідентифікована, як таксі.
Тобто шашечка якась є, чи напис на дверях -
все, зупиняйте, будь ласка, покажи ліцензію.
Немає - штраф 17 000. І що ви думаєте?
Поліція до тепер це рішення не хоче виконувати. Вже два роки пройшло.
Адвокат  закликає авторів законопроєкту врахувати помилки попередніх років
і чітко визначити, як та хто має контролювати таксистів без патентів і ліцензій.
Адвокат пропонує також офіційним таксистам давати можливість спецідентифікації,
приміром, завдяки автономерам відповідного кольору.
Адже якщо ринок зрозуміє, що можна не виконувати правила,
тема легалізації таксі в Україні загальмується ще на кілька років.
Таксист Олександр Петров стежить за обговоренням законопроєкту і усвідомлює,
що у підсумку документ може зазнати ще багатьох змін.
І все ж, він хоче і далі працювати таксистом, готовий придбати патент.
Найбільша перевага в тому, що відпадуть водії,
які просто підзаробляють - "підвезуни".
І тоді зросте робота у постійних водіїв. Цього всі чекаємо.
Дуже багато сумнівів,
тому що в нас країна корумпована...
Де гарантія, що ці гроші не будуть просто розкрадатися?
За задумом авторів законопроєкту, запровадження патентування
дозволить державі на першому етапі отримати приблизно один мільярд гривень на рік
Якщо реформу продовжувати грамотно далі,
то є шанс вивести з тіні більшу частину нелегалів.
У тіньовому ринку таксі, за різними оцінками, може  обертатися
від 2 до навіть 4-х мільярдів гривень готівкою.